I thought I you know we could talk a
little bit about uh digital twins today
um just because you know it's a sort of
buzz word it's been about in the been
been around the blocks a little while
and you may have heard of it uh it and
it's not entirely clear right
immediately is it really a new relevant
important thing should I care about it
what is it even is this just a new cloud
is it is it exactly is it just the new
cloud is it new or is it just sort of
old wine in new bottles as it
were digital twins similar to simulation
isn't it simulation is not not an
unimportant thing in IND digal twins but
it's perhaps not the first thing to
think about I think I think um it's
worth perhaps looking a little bit and
maybe I'll I'll try and sketch something
out there and then we can sort of start
talking a little bit about is it just
simulation or what's what's going on
there you know you ask seven experts on
digital twins you'll get 10 different
definitions of what a digital twin
is I'm not even going to go there right
I'm going to try and keep this really
simple and and and and fairly high level
and just sort of try and work out what
the of the key components and the
biggest two components really are that
we have some sort of actual real world
system which I'm going to put here it
could be anything right it could be a
bridge it could be a human it could be
an organization it could be a car and
then what we do in the digital twin
setup is we create a digital
representation of that real system we
have a digital twin over here and a
digital twin as the name implies is a
digital artifact so it's not something
in the real world it's something that
lives in the computer and depending on
you know what our real system is the
digital twin might just live on a little
desktop PC somewhere or it might you
know require quite a significant sort of
cloud style deployment somewhere um
depending on what we want to do right I
mean there's some people who talk about
building a digital twin of Earth that's
probably not going to fit on the desktop
you'll probably need a fair amount of
computer for that if it's you know a
digital twin of my copty at home which
I've built maybe for for the fun of it
then maybe I've run that on a little
Arduino or something the important thing
is it's connected to this real system
it's connected in two ways we need
sensors on our real system and the twin
uses those to learn about the state of
the real system so it learn it it tries
to work out what's happening in the real
system and it so that it can
maintain a sort of continually upto-date
representation of the real system that
doesn't mean it's millisecond to
millisecond
accurate how accurate how often it keep
gets data from Those sensors depends
really on what we're actually built the
digitals trend for and we'll we'll get
to that in a moment the other thing that
a digital twin typically has to have is
it has to have some way of affecting the
behavior of the real system so it's so
the real system has to provide some ways
of changing it and the the digital twin
will will use those effectors to make
changes now if that is a digital twin
say of a car engine then typically there
little ecus Etc little control devices
built into the car engine that allow the
computer systems of the digital twin to
talk to those little control units and
they can then make adjustments to the
amount of gas that that that that that's
that's being injected or the amount of
air that's or you know whatever other
aspect of of that system uh for other
systems they these effectors may need to
be more complicated things um and again
if we look at say for example
organizations Etc as our real systems
then these effectors can become really
complicated really quickly because they
they really then maybe are about
having a human decision maker in the
lube somehow who then tries to actually
make change in the organization based on
something they've learned from the
digital twin rather than something more
direct like a sort of very close loop
control system the reason why we built
this really and that's the important
thing is because we want to be able to
provide additional Services we've
learned I think over the last 50 60 70
years or so that computers are really
good to keeping track of things they're
really good at helping us plan things
and of doing what if analysis doing
calculations and so on and so
forth but of course they can only do
that if there's
something in the computer to manipulate
and to track and to plan over Etc right
so they need a representation of things
in the real world and if I have a a
bridge like you know waterl Bridge down
the road and I want to maintain that
effectively and the digital twin is
about bringing enough information of the
real real system into the computer
building a model effectively of the real
system in the computer so that the
computer now is able to do analysis on
top of that make plans provide the
decision support or even make decisions
and apply them back to the real system
in some way um and so that's where the
value of of of the digital twin is you
started out early on I think and you
sort of said isn't that just simulation
right and it's lots of things in a way
right we could equally ask isn't that
just modeling you could equally ask
isn't that just AI isn't that just data
science isn't that just uh controlled
systems um isn't that just scada right
there's lots of these these things that
are seemingly doing similar things or I
would argue perhaps are doing part of
this what seems to be different here is
those connections you mentioned senses
to send data so so so that's one I think
that's one thing there are these these
these differ although you know
especially if you look at things like
control systems they kind of have that
as well right or or adaptive systems
they they they kind of have that kind of
notion as well there there's I think
partly a difference in scale there's a
difference in the capabilities that we
typically would then put into these
services in our digital twin if I go
back at the sort of starting point of
sort of is this just a
buzzword is this really something new I
guess the answer is yes and yes right so
so yes of course it's a buzz word
because all of the components and
building blocks are fair we we know how
to build simulations in fact we know how
to build simulations that keep up with
the real
world we know how to do data science and
data analysis and and we have a good
idea nowadays of how to do a lot of AI
stuff but what I think is new is that
this is this makes an emphasis on
bringing all these things together in an
engineered system that represents
something in the real world and allows
us to manage that something and I think
that to me is where the value is and
that to me is also where the challenges
are um because it's not immediately
obvious how do you engineer these kind
of complex software systems at this
scale how do you
bring
complex Concepts and ideas like
simulation like AI like data science
data processing data cleaning like
control systems together in a safe and
robust and assur way um that's
manageable like the humans
developing it that can live a very long
time right if you imagine this is a
digital twin of a bridge again that
bridge is going to be there for
hopefully you know tens hundreds of
years it'd be great if the digital twin
could kind of live alongside it for that
period of time as well but actually
also the bridge is going to change what
we want off the bridge is going to
change over that period of time the
kinds of things that we therefore want
to do with a digital twist are going to
change over that period of
time and arguably we don't know at this
point how to build those sort of systems
that are able to to manage a huge amount
of data about something in the real
world
adaptively allow flexible decision
support or decision making over that
system over the long periods of time and
do that in a world where everything
around that that that real world system
also has a digital twin that also has
ideas of how to manage its part and
ideally should work all of these guys
should work together as well okay so
what what's really happening in here
right because I've sort of tried to make
this this this point about how different
disciplines are involved but but
obviously have been a bit handwavy about
this so maybe if we open up this sort of
digital twin box here for a moment we
can perhaps see that a little bit more
so let's let's see what what happens in
that box right in principle say if I
draw sort of a big box here for our
digital twin then what goes into this
right so we've said it goes and says
well which I'm going to draw this this
way around it has various sensors and
we've said eventually we'd like it to do
things okay so it has to have those
affectors but what happens between this
and that okay and what happens between
this and that is a number of steps right
so we get this data in here so we've got
lots of data and data are really just
numbers okay those numbers they need
cleaning up right because sensors are
fallible they might not always get me
data every time step I'm asking for them
or the data might not be accurate in
fact the real world might be outside of
the range that the sensor can handle um
but also I've got multiple different
sensors and I kind of need to stick them
together right so there's lots of
processing that needs to happen so I've
got a sort of initial just sort of kind
of data cleaning pre-processing I'm
going to call it where the data is
brought in and it's cleaned up to a
standard where we can start doing stuff
with it okay the next step we need to
try and understand what that data means
and so we're going to do what's called
analysis right what we could call what
we could call analysis and that that
really turns data if you will into
information into knowledge and
information and what we do there is we
may combine
different uh different data sources of
different sensors uh we may but also we
we will perhaps already have some
built-in knowledge in
in in our uh in in our system here in
our digital twin where we kind of know
for example we have maybe if this again
if this a digital twins say of of an
aircraft engine we might have a model of
the physics involved in aircraft so that
that helps us make sense of the sensor
data by by saying oh well if that
temperature sensor is at that value then
I can
predict that over here in the in the
engine something interesting is
happening right and or I maybe or I
would expect that sensor value to be in
that kind of range and then if it isn't
then that's an indication that maybe
something has gone wrong right and
that's only possible because I have some
knowledge about the thing that I'm
monitoring that allows me to expect
certain things or that allows me to
infer certain things from the data that
I've collected okay so at the end of
this really what I come out with is is a
sort of upto-date model of the real
system that's what comes out really of
the analysis phase and and what's fed
into this is the data that that that we
collected from the sensors which is kept
in some sort of knowledge model in my in
my digital twin that's also fed into
this analysis that allowed me to to make
the analysis in the first place what I'm
going to do with this model next is is
I'm going
to I've got look at it and I go okay
maybe I just present it to somebody so I
can see it and that's one of the
possible Services I might provide right
is I present this to somebody and I say
okay this is the state of your of your
aircraft engine this is the state of
your healthc care uh emergency
department or this is the state of your
car or your Bridge Etc um great here you
are right that's the first thing I can
do um some people call that a Digital
Shadow because it doesn't actually do
anything through the system it just
Shadows what the system does um but I
can do more potentially right I can do
whatif analysis at this point I can do
uh scenario planning Etc and I would do
that perhaps if the analysis here tells
me how something is not quite right
maybe the system doesn't quite run
optimally or I've spotted a problem uh
something unexpected in my data Etc and
so then I would do some form of what
what what we call planning really I
guess at that point right so for example
what if analysis so what if analysis
typically is if I make this change
change to the system what might happen
right and that's particularly
interesting if if I have a digital twin
say of a soci technical system so where
there's people and Technology involved
say as say one example might be an
emergency care uh
Department um where I don't want to go
in and just go oh right from today we're
going to do everything differently that
probably wouldn't be a good idea so
instead what I can do is I can say okay
I've got a really good model of how my
emergency department works I've got a
good understanding of that I've got data
that comes in I've analyzed this I've
got a reasonable representation I've got
some knowledge about maybe the workflow
processes Etc now what if I made an
adjustment to the work processes or what
if I used a different tests uh from a
different provider perhaps to check for
a particular illness or or or something
like that right what might the outcomes
be like I can analyze that typically
that's where simulation comes in um I
would Analyze This to to sort of run it
in difference in in different context
right I might say okay if I do this what
happens under normal conditions what
happens if my emergency department
sudden is overrun by patience what
happens if half of my staff are ill and
I can really try and explore that and
obviously yes it's all in the digital in
the virtual and it's all sort of at one
remov from the real system and so I need
to take that into account when assessing
the results from that they might not be
a totally accurate reflection of what
happens in the real world but they will
give me an indication of whether this is
a sensible thing to try and do or not
right equally if this is the is if this
is say a digital twin of of an aircraft
engine again I might want to say okay
something's weirds going on based on my
knowledge of the physics and and the
data I have about the current state what
if
I injected more fuel or did that with
that and I can sort of try out different
scenarios there hopefully I then do a
sort of more automated decision making
that then might might actually directly
affect the engine rather than just
providing it as a decision support
system right and so that's sort of what
if analysis is is one of the things I I
might do here um I I could do forward
planning I could sort of try and sort of
you know do do problem solving of that
sort of thing you know the M Rover might
might might do something like that where
it finds itself in a situation that
doesn't quite match the expectation from
from from the mission planning and I and
it kind of has to go right um there's a
stone here I can't go straight what do I
do right and then it needs to work out
where it goes again it needs the digital
representation of itself and its
environment to be able to do that and
that's a digal twin and then eventually
hopefully we get to some sort of
decision making that allows us to say
these are the changes that we're
actually going to implement and again in
the sort of digital twins where as they
come from the manufacturing world and
from the of of aircraft management and
car management and so on
world this we would want to be automated
fully so we'd want to be able to go
around this cycle fully and it just
having a direct effect but there's
nothing wrong with digital twins of say
social Technical Systems Etc where this
decision making might actually be done
by a human and then and then lead to
changes in policy or changes in in in
workflows or or changes in in um the
sourcing of equipment and and so on but
again I think the key thing that you can
see is that there's all kinds of
different disciplines involved right
we've seen all of this over here is all
about data signs and and and data
analysis we've seen seen here uh some
aspects of sort of extracting Knowledge
from data which is very much the sort of
Realm of AI isn't it um we've seen this
sort of planning stage well we've seen
this modeling stage knowledge models and
these models in the M middle here which
is really about knowing how to build
models these could be knowledge graphs
but they could also be more typical sort
of engineering type models right and
then we come to the planning stage which
again could be some AI component that
goes into there or it could be a
simulation components and and and again
needs that exper expertise and then
decision making is a about understanding
the results of that but also about
knowing how to translate that into
signals to be sent to the various
effectors that we actually have
available okay and so so all of these
things have to come together to build to
to to build a digital twin and they have
to come together in a controll
systematic way where ideally we're also
able to afterwards say and we're okay
with relying on that digital twin we've
build it to a sufficient standard of
quality where it's not
scary but it's actually a useful thing
no matter what the system is it's
difficult to get it to be what am I
trying to say not accurate but as
complicated you know even your cup of
tea I remember high school chemistry and
brownie of motion you know how you
decide to what granularity I think
that's a really that's a really good
question right and it's a really
important question because I think
one fallacy I should I'm always tempted
to say in in in some sort of
descriptions of what a digital twin is
is is I think some people call it an an
identical uh digital representation or
or uh you know or like for like or or or
things like that
and of course
that's not right that's that's
fundamentally
impossible but even if it were possible
what why would we right if we if we if
we just want something that's absolutely
identical we have the real thing why not
just use that right the point of the
digital twin is a that we have now a
virtual representation that we can
manipulate more easily and analyze Etc
more easily but also that it's focused
on the things that we're actually
interested in okay so take the example
of the bridge again you know Water
Bridge uh I I'll be interested in in
maintenance Perhaps Perhaps for that
okay so um I need to I need to probably
know uh something about the materials
from which it was constructed and I need
to have some Physics knowledge around
that okay um uh it's probably going to
be useful to have a bit of data about
its usage so you know how many people
walk over it and May maybe even on
average how much they weigh so I get a
bit of a sense for the of load that it
carries that way equally with the cars
right how many cars and what how much
you know how many buses versus how many
uh SUVs versus how many minis I think is
probably a useful sort of information um
and I probably don't just want that as a
sort of one number average but I
probably want some sort of time serious
data about that um it may even be
interesting to know a little bit about
say the weather in particular might be I
I might not care so much about how much
it rains because I probably assume that
maybe that isn't the biggest impact on
on the Decay but maybe I'd be interested
in knowing whether there's any heavy
storms that have affected the bridge
because that may have more of an impact
but again maybe I find out actually you
know I'm not at all a civil engineer so
so it it's entirely possible that waterl
bridge you'd kind of go as a civil
engineer kind of go it really doesn't
matter how much it storm so so I don't
care about that information and then you
leave that out right everything you can
leave out is a good thing but you don't
have to manage it we've talked about
Water Bridge right exists for I don't
know how long it's been standing there
and hopefully it's going to be standing
there for another however many years so
that dig wind needs to live alongside it
over time I might learn I might
say actually I thought the wind isn't
important but it turns out especially
with climate change winds sort of strong
wind events have become more frequent
and I've noticed that that does seem to
have an effect on on the bridge so it
probably would be a good idea to be able
to to include that in my
analysis now what you do right well one
thing is easy right well comparatively
easy you can say okay well I'm going to
build an extension of my existing
digital twin and from now on we're going
to collect data about the weather and
and we're going to include that in our
analysis
but then what about all the storms that
water L bridge is seen before you did
that should you care about those as well
and if so how do you do that if you
haven't collected that data because you
didn't have the sensors so then you can
bring in historical weather data and you
can start building up you
approximations but you've got to build
additional complexity around that at
that point right and so so I think one
of the things that again the digital
twin idea none of this is new in some
ways right but what the digital twin
idea brings is it to focuses in and says
actually you know when we build these
things these are all concerns that we
have to somehow bring together and the
line and make work together and and
really think through as we engineer the
system we've got to work out what's the
minimum data that we need to collect
both for our needs now and for
Meaningful future needs but we don't
want to col too much we got to work out
what granularity do we collect that data
and when do we throw it
away which really you can't keep all of
that data about even even just about
waterl Bridge forever right I mean
that's just very quickly that just
becomes ridiculous so so there's lots of
these sort of engineering questions that
suddenly pop up just because the idea of
digital twins is about taking all of
data signs and simulation and AI
bringing them together to focus on Real
World objects on a continuous and and
sort of long-term adaptive basis and
that's where where it becomes
interesting I
think various places it do have just
hardcoded text but it puts in text that
it copies out from the model right so
it'll go into those into those don't
need to worry about the difference too
much if your Loop or your function does
the same thing repeatedly with only
minor variations this will be very
effective